[Music]
mr. Sakawa
may I present miss Roxanne cause it is a
great pleasure the pleasure's all mine
[Music]
[Music]
I'm with International Committee of the
Red Cross our demands all political
prisoners must be freed it is up to the
government if there is blood it will be
on their hands no one has to die
we'll have to someday
[Music]
he's always moved by your work he must
love opera for him your voice his hopper
professor Mizuki
para buzz' s for the poem is it true
that the government is considering
shooting his own guava vanilla so as to
pin it on the rebels
we need to free your brothers and
sisters
we'll be not surrender to these
government criminals
we hear her only her the good stolen
second how did I do
we will not last long human so let her
go then we can now more than four
[Music]
I want you to see we're good without
there when they spirit the beautiful
boys perhaps they will find a solution
[Music]
I think I should say
[Music]
I want you to sing loudly enough that
these animals outside came here
it's time
[Music]
[Music]
you